ce train monsieur le premier ministre
emmanuel macron a décidé d'organiser le
grand débat concertation
discussions/négociations ouverture
écoute sont les mots que le chef de
l'état martèle à juste titre dans ses
échanges avec les maires et les français
depuis quelques semaines il les place au
il en fait l'alpha et l'oméga de sa
nouvelle méthode de gouvernance et il a
sans doute raison
qu'importe que sa conversion au dialogue
soit tardive elle seule permettra de
sortir de la crise car on ne peut pas
réformer la société par voie d'autorité
cette nouvelle méthode auraient-elles
échapper à votre gouvernement une
réforme de la justice contre l'ensemble
des professionnels du droit
magistrats avocats greffiers sans écoute
des propositions du sénat qui vous a
tendu la main pourtant avec notamment
une table ronde un projet de loi santé
contre les professionnels du secteur
tous dénoncent un texte élaboré sans
concertation et dont l'essentiel des
propositions sera formalisée par
ordonnance 'l'annonce d'une réduction
des dessertes tgv
je ne crois pas avoir entendu les
français formulé une telle demande pas
même dans les grands débats une carte
pénitentiaire imposé aux élus locaux
sans dialogue ni concertation des
ordonnances pour réformer la politique
des déchets dois-je rappeler ici le
travail colossal des parlementaires sur
ce sujet comme sur d'autres sujets que
je viens d'évoquer
pourquoi mettre les parlementaires à
distance monsieur le premier ministre
vous pouvez le constater les exemples ne
manquent ne manquent pas ils sont
nombreux je suis pourtant convaincu que
la voie de l'apaisement est celle que
vous recherchez alors qu'attendez vous
pour mettre en oeuvre dans votre
politique la seule méthode qui vaille
celle de la concertation pour répondre
au rôle et au ministre chargé des
relations avec le parlement monsieur
marc raynaud la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur ps
j'aurais vous remercier du là votre
question et du ton de votre question
parce que je pense qu'au moment du grand
débat on a besoin les uns les autres à
la fois de pouvoir débattre et en même
temps de pouvoir débattre sereinement et
c'est ce que vous avez fait je voulais
vous en remercier
vous alerter le gouvernement sur à la
fois le travail du grand des bandes
jaunes en dix ans et nous partageons
évidemment ce sentiment l'utilité de ce
grand débat est par ailleurs la
traduction législative à la manière dont
nous pourrions travailler avec le
parlement et vous noté un certain nombre
de textes sur lequel il peut y avoir des
désaccords
dois je vous rappeler aussi qu'il ya un
certain nombre de textes y compris avec
le sénat je pense à la loi ferroviaire
par exemple nous avons trouvé des
accords et donc je pense qu'il faut
qu'on assume et c'est aussi la loi
démocratique le fait que nous puissions
sur un certain nombre de textes actes et
des désaccords et parfois même trouvé
des convois de convergence partiel et
puis sur d'autres textes qu'avec le
sénat qu'avec l'assemblée nationale au
travers des navettes ou à travers des
commissions mixtes nous puissions
trévoux de trouver des points d'accord
le grand débat est encore à l'oeuvre
le président de la république et le
premier ministre ont annoncé un certain
nombre d'étapes qui nécessairement
auront leur traduction législative à ce
moment là il y aura un débat au
parlement et nous comptons bien que le
parlement puisse se saisir de ces
questions parce que comme vous l'avez
dit le débat est nécessaire le débat
avec les français nécessaire mais la
démocratie représentative doit être
aussi renforcé dans son rôle d'interface
entre les citoyens et le gouvernement et
donc nous comptons bien travailler avec
le parlement le sénat et l'assemblée
nationale pour trouver des points de
convergence mais je dois vous l'avez il
se trouvera aussi des configurations où
l'on puisse ne pas trouver doit de
convergence et c'est aussi ça en
démocratie je vous remercie monsieur
perrin se mêler je vous remercie pour
dialoguer il faut être deux et si le
décalage entre les annonces qui sont
fait qu'ils sont en train d'être fait
encore part le président en ce moment et
les actes se confirme le remède pourrait
être pire que le mal est sans doute que
la déception sera à la hauteur des
espoirs que les annonces ont provoqué